je crois que l'univers de l'animation au
canada
g
en général travail et aux cadeaux mais
avec des projets bien des étudiants de
les états unis mais aucun d'eux on a
beaucoup différents comme on voit ce
cette conférence de trafi on voit
beaucoup de différents des gens qui
s'appelait qui travaillent dans les
différents domaines
mettez des gens qui travaillent dans les
studios et déjà qu'ils travaillent sont
des indépendants qui ont une action qui
travaillent qui dominèrent comme le
défend trop élèves on est chanceux
d'être au canada lorsqu'il ya beaucoup
on a la chance d'appliquer pour des
bourses et les filles chloé neves sodec
je crois pour c'est pour ça que
l'animation et fritz c'est tellement
diversifiée parce qu'il ya non seulement
beaucoup de studios puis surtout
montréal ubisoft fera encore mieux
beaucoup d'animations à marianne dans
des mines puis le beaucoup de dépendance
ou de jacky qui ont des petites boîtes
qui font toutes sortes de choses et
comme nous on fait des annonces
commencent à des fois on va faire
des documentaires aussi qui exige de
l'animation c'est vraiment été notre
projet qu'on travaille avec des
documentaires qui veut juste expliquer
quelque chose mais en utilisant
l'animation 5,6 le beaucoup de fonds que
ça peut prendre
à taranto aussi
animations semblent ave maria je croyais
pt - des pans de bois était dépendant et
plus de gros studios
mais ça commence quand même 2 avec
l'internet et d'accessibilité de pouvoir
montrer une autre avec comme seuls les
insulaires ma crainte du coup plus de
faire section intéresser surtout des
cours forme à l'animation
fecteau et y'a pas un manque de travail
les gens que je connais qui travaillent
ici surtout dans le domaine commercial
il ya vraiment beaucoup d'animations qui
ce qui se fait ici puis je sais la
plupart des gens qui je parle lyon aucun
intérêt d'aller aux états unis on croit
toujours que j'ai plus de travail là bas
m'a relaté on apprend ici pour te
demande c'est un an